non
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo nous sommes à strasbourg au
parlement européen
dans cette édition direction la grande
bretagne un pays où sous l'impulsion du
parti you keep indépendantistes et
conservateurs l'immigration est au coeur
des débats
nous en débattrons avec nos invités mais
d'abord l'actualité
les européens sont vent debout contre
leurs alliés américains motifs
l'espionnage de la msa
alors comme ça les etats-unis s ken
l'europe et la france en particulier
grandes entreprises cabinets
ministériels live et ça aurait engrangé
plus de 70 millions de communications en
un mois non comment cela est possible
comment peut-on être espionnés par ses
alliés du coup paris s'excite exige des
explications qu'on voit que
l'ambassadeur américain mais promis nous
cherchons pas des salades
après ces révélations voilà qu'est 28
font mine de découvrir les opérations
d'espionnage de leur grand frère
américain un peu facile si l'espionnage
des voisins a toujours existé force est
de constater qu'à l'heure du cyber
espace
la tâche est plus complexe alors
l'europe est-elle prête à protéger les
données de ses citoyens et pour évoquer
cette question de la protection vous des
données des citoyens européens c'est
jean marie cavada qui m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau merci d'être avec nous bonjour
bon choix
bonjour boursiers alors on a un petit
peu l'impression que finalement quelques
mois après laffaire prisme que l'union
européenne et a fortiori la france
redécouvre que les états unis nous
espionnent est ce que il n'y a pas une
petite part de naïveté là dedans pour
vous dire le niveau de mon raisonnement
j'ai réclamé un passeport européen pour
snowden parce que je trouve que la sntf
dont qui a révélé m café les révélations
actuellement en russie et qui est
actuellement réfugié en russie à
l'aéroport si ma mémoire est bonne il a
eu un visa d'un an ou un lézard voilà
toujours est il que voilà un homme sans
lequel nous n'aurions pas la moindre
idée de l'ampleur des écoutes parce que
de quoi s'agit-il que les services
secrets s'espionnent mutuellement est
une tradition de surveillance classique
et même entre alliés c'est une très
vieille et ça n'a jamais cessé donc je
je veux pas parler de ça je dirais que
ce sont les risques du métier et puis ça
fait partie des pratiques
en revanche je vois pas comment on peut
s'autoriser à écouter la société civile
vos moi tout le monde dans tous les sens
et en plus
des dizaines et des dizaines de millions
des coûts de cibler en à moi ça veut
dire que des personnalités meadow de des
gens anonymes ou qui ont une un profil
intéressant pour les intérêts
économiques des états unis parce qu'il
s'agissait essentiellement à écouter
alcatel lucent d'un côté wanadoo orange
de l'autre entre autres oui c'est ça
donc là yvan ils vont sur des
fournisseurs donc c'est internet
c'est extrêmement pratique ça leur évite
des deux branches et 80 millions de
lignes mais toujours est il que c'est un
principe absolument scandaleux et je
comprends même pas qu'ils aient une
discussion sur ce sujet je suis moi je
me mets à vous écoutez je vais en prison
pourquoi un état qui écoute des citoyens
ne peut pas faire l'objet d'une heure
d'une sanction est en tout cas alors
qu'elle initiation politique d'une
sanction jean marie cavada vis-à-vis de
cet allié américain de ce grand frère
qui vous écoute
alors il a écouté les français il a
écouté les autrichiens il a écouté les
allemands ils appellent tous ceux qui
toussent et anglais alors guère
déterminable ça c'est pas la peine
d'avoir la même chambre à coucher
si c'est pour se faire espionner comme
ça bon passons mais ce qui est très
choquant c'est encore une fois les
coudes des citoyens que le viol des
faits quelle sanction
mon sentiment c'est que l'europe devrait
être beaucoup plus dur est beaucoup plus
ferme dans cette affaire et suspendre
les négociations qui sont chères aux
états unis parce que les états unis
veulent agrandir la marché et dans
lequel nous trouvons quelque intérêt
nous aussi puisque nous espérons pouvoir
ouvrir un peu mieux les négociations du
traité de libre échange
absolument oui absolument nous devrions
suspendre ces négociations j'aurais été
avez vous sur cette question parce que
finalement il s'est plutôt avec l'élite
rennes gauche sur ce pas l'extrême non
non pas du tout non non les verts en
parle aussi une partie des libéraux
également ceux qui sont libertaire ceux
qui sont très soucieux de la
préservation des libertés individuelles
à gauche il y a un fort une forte
comment dirais-je un fort volume de gens
qui sont favorables à la suspension pour
une raison simple c'est que nous
devrions pouvoir composer une majorité
pour voter cette décision à ce jour
probablement nous ne l'avons pas mais
c'est surtout que la question est posée
si mollement qu'on se sent presque gêné
de dire ce que je viens de dire mais non
enfin sais de la morale ordinaire dans
la politique des états en traitant un
peu de morale ne fait pas ne fait pas de
mal non plus oui mais alors là je vais
revenir après tout sur les manquements
de l'union européenne sur cette question
la dernière directive qui protège les
données des citoyens 22,95 dans l'ue
autant dire la préhistoire d'internet
est-ce qu'il ya pas eu de lacunes aussi
de la part de l'union européenne sur
cette incontestable le mans il y à une
lacune qui n'a pas été comblé dans les
négociations que nous avons eues j'étais
alors président de la commission des
libertés civiles précisément que nous
avons avec les états unis après le 11
septembre 2001 par les attentats de
madrid 2004 et de londres de du jeudi 7
juillet 2005
par conséquent nous ne sommes pas allés
au bout de ce que nous devrions faire
pour protéger les valeurs qui sont une
de nos revendications de la construction
de l'europe
nous devons aller encore plus loin parce
que l'europe est là elle a une fonction
très très basique c'est d'essayer d'être
un bloc continental de haut niveau
démocratique et dans la démocratie à la
préservation des libertés individuelles
et collectives faut reprendre ce dossier
il faut construire quelque chose de plus
solide et s'agissant des états unis je
le répète nous n'avons pas de raison de
ne pas faire un coup de semonce les
états unis et l'administration
américaine doit dire à ses services de
renseignements de cesser de d'espionner
les les individus des sociétés en eux et
en europe comme ailleurs d'ailleurs
qu'il l'a fâché je sais les regarde en
europe ça ne nous regarde
alors justement le président le
directeur de la nsa a répondu à toutes
ces allégations il y a déjà quelques
semaines dans l'écoutent
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
nous n'écoutons pas leurs appels
téléphoniques ne consultant pas leurs
emails
nous défendons ce pays et nous le ferons
comme il se doit
nous prenons nos responsabilités nous
rendrons compte de chaque incident mais
nous avons besoin d'outils pour protéger
ce pays si on nous enlève ses outils
regardez ce qui s'est passé la semaine
dernière que se passera-t-il à l'avenir
ma préoccupation est la suivante vous
pensez que la situation est grave en ce
moment mais si vous arrivez quelque
chose de similaire à ce qui s'est
déroulé à nairobi des choses serait
vraiment différente
jean marie cavada est ce que la fin
justifie les moyens est ce que le
patriot act américain n'a pas été trop
loin et pour protéger les états unis
deux choses ceux qui se plaignent ou se
méfie de l'europe devrait regarder
devant leur porte
le patriot act américain a fait reculer
les libertés individuelles et les
libertés collectives beaucoup plus que
les libertés ne n'ont été endommagé en
europe nous avons veillé à ce que
l'équilibré sécurité liberté après ces
attentats restent importants restent
normalement protégés c'est pas le cas
aux états unis dont avait même une des
mères de la démocratie eh ben c'est
liberté ont été mises à mal les
deuxièmement dans ces conditions non la
fin ne justifie pas les moyens je dirais
d'ailleurs à ce monsieur qu'il ment et
que deuxièmement si vous vous souvenez
du 11 septembre 2001 plusieurs agences
de renseignement savaient et ils y
avaient européennes et américaines je
parle des américaines
en l'occurrence savait que des personnes
prenait des cours de pilotage chez eux
et avaient fréquenté les cours
d'instruction générale et les cours de
décollage mais n'était pas venu au cours
qui apprenaient à theillay moi je suis
pilote de amateurs dans l'habillage
pilote dacia une chose qui est très
importante c'est pas des années cette
supposée 1 donc il le savait mais la
guerre des agences de renseignement fait
que ces renseignements ne leur ont pas
été échangé ni communiqué donc qui
balaye devant sa porte et deuxièmement
la fin ne justifie pas les moyens
la lutte contre le terrorisme est une
chose nécessaire surveiller les
transactions financières c'est
nécessaire
et pas aux prix des libertés
individuelles mais pas aux meadows mais
on ne me fera pas croire qu'on écoute en
france en un mois de temps 80 millions
de personnes au motif au motif de lui
contre les russes il s'agit d'un
espionnage économique au prorata des
intérêts économiques américains comme
beaucoup d'autres grandes puissances
hélas le fond ça doit cesser y'a pas à
discuter de ces choses ça doit cesser
merci beaucoup jean marie cavada d'avoir
été avec nous pour évoquer ces questions
nous on continue direction le kent
là-bas de nombreux bulgares ou roumains
travaillent dans les fermes pour autant
le gouvernement souhaite réfréner cette
immigration
direction l'angleterre avec le rat
sauvage
le gouvernement britannique ouvre un
nouveau front la lutte contre
l'immigration illégale juillet 2013
une campagne anti immigrés s'étale dans
les rues de londres et fait les gros
titres des journaux télévisés un
durcissement de la politique
d'immigration qui inquiète plusieurs
secteurs d'activité en manque de main
d'oeuvre comme l'agriculture
alasdair brooks emploi depuis des années
des étrangers pour cueillir ses fraises
et framboises les au 1er janvier 2014 le
programme de travailleurs agricoles
saisonniers qui lui permet d'embaucher
pendant six mois des roumains des
bulgares va arriver à son terme le but
privilégier les travail et un
britannique
sur les 200 travailleurs saisonniers qui
sont ici environ 180 sont étrangers
petru à 32 ans dès que la saison est
terminée
il repart en roumanie c'est ma dixième
année oui c'est ça c'est ma dixième
année c'était une très bonne opportunité
quand j'étais étudiant et puis ensuite
j'ai eu mon diplôme j'ai fini
l'université que finalement j'ai
continué parce que ça ça me plaît les
agriculteurs comme à laser peine à
recruter des britanniques pour
travailler aux champs pour ramasser ses
fruits il emploie donc des roumains des
bulgares des polonais mais aussi des
espagnols
où êtes vous à vous êtes au numéro 5 ha
ok on y était presque
on arrive à tout fait on n'arrive pas à
trouver à cette gens dans le kent qu'ils
soient prêts à travailler dans les
champs
car c'est un travail temporaire on est
donc obligé d'embaucher des gens qui
viennent de l'étranger
bonjour peter voici peter et roxana qui
dirige une équipe vous êtes combien
aujourd'hui en venant travailler en
grande bretagne roxana peut doubler son
salaire et vivre correctement roumanie
ici on gagne plus d'argent
en roumanie on gagne 200 livres en un
mois seulement tout le monde ici vient
pour l'argent
alasdair brooks appréhende les effets de
la fin du programme qui lui permettait
d'embauché roumains et bulgares
car sans cueilleurs ses fraises et
framboises ne pourront pas être récoltés
en fait ce qui va se passer c'est que la
production horticole va être exporté à
l'étranger on voit déjà des producteurs
de salades au royaume uni avec des
business en bio en pologne
ils sont basés ici mais leur production
est en europe de l'est
et ça va pas s'arrêter après ça sera la
russie la chine mais ça va aussi être
ailleurs les conséquences du repli sur
soi pourrait être dramatique pour
l'industrie comme le redoute l'union
nationale des agriculteurs
le comble c'est que jusqu'ici nous
autorisions 21 mille travailleurs
saisonniers à venir ici et ensuite 99%
d'entre eux repartent chez eux mais
dorénavant en mettant un terme à ce
programme de travailleurs agricoles
ils pourront venir et travailler de
manière permanente
donc cette mesure va en fait augmenter
potentiellement le nombre d'immigrés au
royaume uni
sous la pression du parti ukip le
gouvernement cherche par tous les moyens
à réduire le nombre d'immigrés ce soir
là un débat réuni nigel farrage le
leader du parti eurosceptique et
d'autres orateurs au centre des
discussions la question de l'immigration
juste une question
trois cent mille emplois ont été créés
l'année dernière un tiers de ces emplois
est allé au britannique et les deux
tiers à des travailleurs nés à
l'étranger
vous trouvez ça normal populiste nigel
farrage agite le spectre de l'invasion
d'étrangers qui mettrait à mal la
cohésion de la société anglaise cette
blague rhymes and est formel enrique
avec tony blair au pouvoir 4 millions
d'immigrés sont venus royaume uni un
chiffre considérable qui a conduit à des
changements radicaux et maintenant la
majorité du pays dit attendez je n'ai
jamais voulu on doit avoir une politique
d'immigration dont le principe est de
faire venir des gens sans casier
judiciaire sans maladie et avec tes
compétences alors en 2004 déjà la grande
bretagne avait ouvert ses portes à la
pologne qui venait d'entrer dans l'union
neuf ans après un demi million
d'immigrés comme ukash se sont installés
outre manche et le polonais est devenue
la deuxième langue parlée en angleterre
pour le représentant des polonais de
grande bretagne
le discours anti-immigrés ambiant est
l'éternel débat qui agite le royaume uni
en 2004 la grande bretagne avait besoin
de sang frais parce que l'économie était
en pleine expansion
mais maintenant le contexte est très
différent aujourd'hui
après neuf ans la situation économique
n'est pas très bonne et les gens ont un
peu peur
tiraillé par les bons scores du you keep
dévide cameron veut se montrer
inflexible sur la question de
l'immigration
mais ses marges de manoeuvre sont
limitées car les règles de libre
circulation en europe s'applique à tous
y compris à la grande bretagne
et pour évoquer cette épineuse question
de l'immigration de travail ce sont deux
députés qui nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau merci d'être avec nous graham
watson vous êtes anglais membres du
parti libéral et démocrate et philippe
juvin vous êtes membre du groupe ppe
donc l'ump en france messieurs à la
suite de la vision de ce reportage
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire
graham watson est ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui que l'angleterre est mise à
mal par cette invasion de roumains et
bulgares tels que nigel farrage
aujourd'hui le plat présente non pas du
tout j'allais au forage des montres clos
sont partis en réalité c'est une partie
contre les immigrés c'est une partie
comme le front national en france ou
autres centrales à 60 dexter ce qui est
important pour nous et surtout pour
l'économie de la grande-bretagne
c'est que nous avons la possibilité de
trouver du main d'oeuvre en roumanie en
bulgarie en pologne pour nous aider avec
les emplois où on n'a pas assez de gens
ou les britanniques ne veulent pas
travailler et ce n'est pas seulement
l'agriculture c'est aussi les abattoirs
c'est les maisons des retraites réelles
et les retraités c'est les hôpitaux
c'est parfois les écoles nous n'avons
pas assez d'instituteurs et
d'institutrices sait conduire les
camions toute une série de ce sont des
emplois en fait de base finalement ce ne
sont pas des emplois très qualifiés les
emplois de base et les gens sont prêts à
venir sans lesquelles on ne pourrait pas
avoir ou connaître le succès économique
quelqu'un comme donc l'économie anglaise
en a besoin est ce que c'est le cas en
france fidji 20 ans fait toute la
difficulté du débat c'est de savoir si
les états définissent correctement les
critères d'entrée sur leur territoire au
fond la france la grande-bretagne tous
les pays ont besoin d'une immigration et
je rappelle que l'europe est une terre
d'émigration
la france par exemple est la nation qui
en europe a accueilli le plus d'immigrés
depuis l'an mil les historiographes is
des historiens transfère d'une
immigration intra européennes on parle
des roumains des bulgares cent mille
polonais absent c'est une sélection
décision du circuit la championne est ce
que vous pouvez mettre en place des
critères
sachant que normalement c'est la libre
circulation des biens
des personnes mais je pense que chaque
économie doit définir le profil des gens
qui sont nécessaires à son bon
fonctionnement
donc ça veut dire restreindre la libre
circulation je pense qu'il ya un très
bon système qui est le système qui est
en vogue en amérique du nord au canada
en particulier qui défie qui permet à
l'état simplement de définir de qui elle
a besoin et l'étain des finissants de
qui elle a besoin elle fait entrer des
quotas de gens en fonction des besoins
de son économie
il n'y a rien que de très normal non
mais certes mais là je vais revenir à la
question initiale c'est que le canada
n'est pas inséré dans une union
européenne ou le principe de libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
et notamment l'immigration de travail
existe donc est ce que cela voudrait
dire selon vous qu'il faudrait remettre
en place une forme de restriction pour
certaines populations l'union européenne
pour qu'elle ne puisse pas accéder au
marché du travail anglais au marché du
travail français belge allemand
mais si vous voulez dans un pays où il y
a plusieurs millions de chômeurs de
longue durée comme la france il me
paraît indispensable de donner du
travail d'abord à ce français de
citoyenneté ou français d'adoption qui
sont sur notre territoire et qui ont
besoin d'un travail donc je pense qu'il
est nécessaire et logique
avant d'ouvrir les frontières de la
france en disant venez travailler chez
nous de voir si on peut donner ces
emplois à ceux qui résident son
territoire ça paraît logique
alors juste un petit mot sur l'action
contre les instituts et les contrôles
internes pourquoi parce qu'il ya deux
faces de cette question nous avons
beaucoup de britanniques et beaucoup de
français qui vont ailleurs dans l'union
européenne pour travailler pour vivre
pour étudier nous savons par exemple qui
a presque un demi million de
britanniques en espagne et à 200 milles
en france il y à au moins deux cent
mille français en grande bretagne et
donc notamment un monde a besoin et
bénéficient de cette capacité d'aller
trouver du travail ailleurs
sssa l'union européenne c'est ça la
liberté que nous nous réjouissons alors
justement je voudrais qu'on écoute une
petite intervention de
votre premier ministre david cameron sur
cette question
nous ne pouvons encourager une culture
du quelque chose en échange de rien et
nouveaux immigrés ne devrait pas
s'attendre à recevoir un logement en
arrivant pourtant de nos jours presque
un dixième des nouveaux logements
sociaux sont attribués à des immigrés je
vais donc introduire de nouvelles
directives législatives pour
l'attribution des logements au printemps
pour créer un test de résidence locale
cela veut dire que les locaux auront la
priorité au niveau des logements sociaux
et que les immigrés devront avoir vécu
et contribuer au pays pendant deux ans
pour être pris en compte vos graham
watson vous votre parti participe à la
coalition de monsieur cameron est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée de
préférence nationale
non je pense que sa stratégie est
mauvaise pourquoi est elle mauvaise
passe que ce qu'il fait c'est de
répondre aux attaques faites par
l'extrême droite ce n'est pas de
défendre le système actuel en disons
pourquoi il est tellement valable est en
effet au sein du gouvernement cameron a
voulu faire beaucoup de choses et nous
l'avons maintenu longtemps empêché parce
que nous avons dit le système actuel et
beneficial pour le business britanniques
mais aussi pour les citoyens et donc il
peut parler il peut dire qu'il va faire
toute une seule une forme de contrôle
mais la réalité c'est qu'il n'a pas de
majorité parlementaire pour le faire
donc il ne peut pas le faire pourtant il
ya un moment où il faut bien
effectivement contrôlé un petit peu ce
qui rentre je reprend les arguments de
philippe juvin est-ce que vous pouvez
aujourd'hui en angleterre vous permettre
avec 9% de chômage d'accueillir bulgares
roumains polonais
et c'est le débat qui agite un petit peu
l'angleterre en ce moment remettre un
petit peu en question cette idée de
multiculturalisme contrôle et bien sûr
ce que nous avons fait ce que le
gouvernement là travailliste n'avait pas
fait nous avons des contrôles pour
savoir qui entre et qui part de la
grande-bretagne
ça c'est important pour toute une série
de raisons y compris lutter contre la
criminalité organisée
donc les contraintes c'est important
mais le multiculturalisme acquis à
londres à fonctionne très très bien
c'est quelque chose de valable pour
notre société femme n'est pas d'accord
non mais en fait il faut bien comprendre
que malheureusement c'est ainsi
l'immigration a évolué dans son dans sa
justification
nous avons eu pendant longtemps une
immigration qui était une immigration
d'adhésion à des valeurs on venait en
grande bretagne on venait en france
parce qu'on a des règles et principes à
des valeurs aujourd'hui une amélioration
besoin d'eux est désormais des amis qui
dénombre désormais l'immigration
effectivement peut devenir en grande
partie une immigration économique et une
immigration de libre shopping ce que
nous pensons second gazon il est normal
qu'un état puisse définir des règles qui
lui permettent de définir qui entre 6 il
n'y a pas ces règles
celui-ci ait pas ces règles si ça
devient contrat unilatéral sur devient
non unilatérale est aussi et moi je ne
veux pas empêché les jeunes français qui
veulent venir travailler en grande
bretagne mais définit ces conditions
définition des conditions il semble que
les conditions ne soient pas défini elle
est là la question je pense qu'un état a
le droit de définir les conditions qui
font que l'on réside sur son territoire
sinon cela devient comme un contrat
unilatérale ou une seule des parties en
l'occurrence la personne qui
décideraient d'entrée fick serait elle
même les conditions ce sont ses jours
c'est ça que nous ne voulons pas nous
voulons qu'il y est un à la fois des
droits des devoirs
oui exactement et les conditions sont
déjà là dans la loi au niveau européen
c'est vrai que certains veulent encore
des conditions moi personnellement je ne
suis pas convaincu et je ne veux pas
qu'elle l'europe se met dans une
atmosphère de donner la culpabilité aux
étrangers
pour les choses qui ne vont pas bien
alors justement ces conditions par
exemple elle existe un petit peu en
france il ya des listes d'emplois qui
sont ouvertes où non exactes au bulgaro
roumain mais finalement ça n'a pas non
plus réglé le problème en france et on
est encore dans l'idée de durcir donc
vous êtes en train de promener quelque
chose pour nos amis anglais qui ne
marchent déjà pas en france d'abord je
ne me permettrais pas de prenez quoi que
ce soit pour nos amis britanniques voulu
là qu'est la question est simple c'est
que je suis issu d'un pays qui est un
pays qui est accueillant pour toutes les
populations de la planète entière la
france a toujours accueilli tout le
monde mais elle accueilli parce que les
gens qui venaient chez nous avait une
volonté d'intégration et la vraie
question au fond nouvelle qui se pose
c'est la capacité d'intégration est ce
que nos sociétés ont encore la capacité
à faire en sorte que les gens qui
viennent s'intègre moi je crois que le
multiculturalisme n'est pas une bonne
chose je pense que dans une nation on
doit cohabiter avec des principes et des
valeurs communes le pire c'est vrai ça
avoir des gens qui sont étrangers
eux-mêmes alors qu'ils habitent eux
mêmes dans le même pays et la mer et la
même ville le système français
traditionnel d'intégration républicain
quel est il
quand vous arrivez en france que vous
soyez italiens polonais algériens
marocains britannique
si l'or vous devez vous voulez devenir
français
eh bien vous adhérer à des valeurs moi
j'ai des je suis comme beaucoup de
français issus de populations immigrées
de différents pays
mais je n'ai pas souvenir que mes
ancêtres quand ils sont venus
revendiquer le droit à cultiver leur
différence parce qu'il venait d'un
endroit étrange et il était au contraire
heureux de se fondre dans la nation
alors cette notion de nation est
fondamental pour nous c'est justement
c'est contrairement à la france
l'angleterre c'est pas du tout construit
comme ça
est ce que vous direz que le pacte
social anglais est en danger non je ne
pense pas que le pacte social soit en
danger
mais je suis d'accord avec cuivres du
vin que l'intégration c'est quelque
chose de très important et il nous faut
des politiques positives d'un stade pour
encourager l'intégration dans chaque
pays ça c'est clair moi je viens de me
minorité je suis écossais je suis
britannique mais je ne suis pas anglais
et je ne
pas souffrir ceux qui ont souffert mes
ancêtres par le fait d'être écossais en
angleterre ou bien dans ces temps
pourtant pourquoi pour parler pourquoi
je dis ça vous pose est pourquoi en
grande bretagne il existe cette question
de multiculturalisme en france le modèle
républicain de la nation intégratrice a
permis l'intégration pendant des années
et je crois que ce modèle est en panne
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai débat interne
à la france en grande bretagne vous
n'avez pas eu ce système d'intégration
c'est on apprenait à tous les français
d'où qu'ils viennent tous les enfants
non français qui allaient à l'école nos
ancêtres sont les gaulois c'était le
système qui permettait par une bâton
magique de dire regardez nous sommes
tous issus du même si oui mais qui a
parfois été remis en question par le
fait d'avoir annulé une partie de la
population notamment seront appelés
indigènes à l'époque et ne pas
reconnaître non c'est justement la gamme
so c'est justement la question des bas
pension qui voudrait juste sur la
question à fond condamnation est de la
bullshit la mort garé là la grande
question et doivent-ils ou pas intégré
du coup l'espace schengen n'est pas le
même débat c'est ça fait partie du débat
cette particularité ce n'est pas moi
j'ai il me semble la question schengen
est très simple fond c'est que dès lors
que nous sommes dans un espace schengen
commun les frontières de mes voisins
sont mes frontières les frontières de
l'italie sont mes fonctions les
frontières de la france et donc à partir
du moment où les frontières de cette
grand ensemble ne sont pas correctement
surveillés en tout cas ne sont pas
surveillés de la même manière cela me
pose un problème à moi manque de 7,7
ensemble que nous pensons nous à l'ump
qu'il faut aujourd'hui renégocier les
conditions de surveillance des
frontières schengen pour faire en sorte
pour faire en sorte que cela fonctionne
mieux par exemple je sois moi si ça ne
fonctionne pas en sortir avec l'appui
des états membres parce que les états
membres en ce moment ne donnent pas leur
appui à une contrôle comme une frontière
commune
il n'y a pas de politique commune il y à
certains instruments comme le frontex
il y aura maintenant l'hérault sur pour
pop aurait des mai mai
les états membres ne veulent pas le
financer en effet ils n'acceptent pas
leur responsabilité au sein de l'union
écoutez on aura au moins réussi à vous
mettre d'accord sur le fait qu'il n'y a
pas de politique commune aux matières
division food une et qu'il en faut une
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir été avec
nous non c'est terminé pour cette
semaine rendez vous dans quinze jours à
bruxelles avec ahmed tazir bonne suite
de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires
en 1900